after Donald Trump hosted a historic
bipartisan televised meeting Mika
Brzezinski and her ventriloquist dummy
Joe said it was awesome now they trashed
it this was nothing more than a dog and
pony show where he was using Democrats
and Republicans to try and show that he
was fit when in truth he actually showed
that he had very little command of the
issue really funny all right so he's
vilified for being partisan vilified for
being bipartisan vilified for not
compromising vilified for compromising
and all by the same Talking Heads
so who sounds mentally unbalanced now
anyway how do you know when you're
losing an argument when you can't even
give just a little bit of credit to your
foe confidence is shown when you're
willing to say when the other guy scores
but there are others who can't check out
this haircut just days after the release
of that bombshell book fire and fury
that claimed some closest to the
president have questioned the
president's fitness to lead an extremely
rare event playing out on television
today reporters and cameras invited into
a bipartisan meeting on immigration
playing out for 55 minutes on television
showing America the president at work
yeah I'm sure that guy reads a time he
subscribes to international mousse and
gel monthly he has amazing hair have you
ever seen that at least one person gave
Trump credit but Lum boo compliments of
south-north dialogue was largely
credited to President Trump I would like
to express gratitude to him isn't that
sweet moon is over the moon now he could
be saying it to flatter Trump knowing
he's a sucker for it but so what what
would you rather have a president who
seeks credit for a job well done or one
willing to look the other way when a
terror group might muddle his legacy now
here's something else Trump's not
getting credit for the small business
optimism index is at a record high you
can tell you can tell because of the
green arrow see it's going up I'm
thinking business optimism is it decent
barometer of job approval more so than
what the media or polls tell you both
get more wrong than right these days
the small businesses thrive in good
times and now they sense good times and
I should know I'm a small piece of
business myself let's talk about let's
Donald Trump commented on his own
meeting it was vintage Trump those were
all that my performance
you know some of them called it a
performance I consider it work
but got great reviews by everybody other
than two networks who were phenomenal
for about two hours then after that they
were called by their bosses oh wait a
minute
and unfortunately a lot of those anchors
sent us letters saying that was one of
the greatest meetings they've ever
witnessed and they were great for about
two hours they were phenomenal and then
they went a little bit south orders but
not that bad so Jesse yesterday you have
this kind of a mixing of moment and then
you have this which is vintage
they said him letters that's pretty
quick it was performance but I mean it
was work it was work performance I
thought it was great but this is just
the media obsessed with the president's
style and not his results remember he
got mocked for the whole fire and fury
and the sanctions now they're talking
north and south yeah he got mocked for
saying he wants to bomb the hell out of
Isis now the caliphates gone remember he
said he wanted the NATO members to pony
up everyone said oh he's gonna pull out
of NATO what happened they Pony DUP so
the tax cuts to remember this is all
going to be for the rich now millions of
people get $1,000 bonus
come Christmastime so the workers did
benefit so I wish just the media would
be fair and you know you could knock him
on the style because the style sometimes
a little erratic but to his credit the
results are there and he's going to be
judged by those results come election
day Dana this I I came across the small
business index I won't say where but
Scott Adams his blog there's a story
conveniently overlooked that's kind of a
big deal right I mean I don't we I feel
like the economy is car
every single day but I guess the first
ever heard of this small business index
being at an all-time high
should that be all over the place yes
thank you now you can now you can go on
and talk about anything else
obviously fully recovered and people are
seeing the benefits of it and I you know
it part of it is just a feeling I mean
as much as you want for someone to
actually get credit and and say like yes
you got credit you got credit there is
that but it's more important that people
actually feel it and I think that when
the economics catches up with the
people's feelings about the tax cuts
that the Republican Party and president
Trump will benefit but most importantly
is that the worker benefits especially
if we just start to correct Kimberly I
know that Juan thinks that the whole
North Korea thing was just baloney but
that was pretty but why question the
intent I mean how is this a bad thing
except well no I think it's good that
he's getting praised because we're
saying look we're working cooperatively
and ultimately we want to go against
North Korea and get them to knock it off
so the more partnerships that we have
and coalition building and support that
is verbalized internationally it is very
good for the United States I think it's
something that's very powerful and
that's something that the president can
use as an asset I see it from that
perspective in terms of okay give me
your voice on this so that we can then
spread the word so it's not just the
president always having to make stand
alone on this no one if you just admit
that there are one or two good things
about your adversary doesn't it make
your other criticism look more valid
like okay so here's your chance one or
two things I love you're here
with David Muir mirror yes pretty good
yes it is and it's real is it real or
real oh because there were lots of
reports of like surgeries and comb-overs
but you think it's real well I know it's
real you had the right notion which was
flattery will get you every and with
Trump that's proven every day so what
you get is president moon who has said
previously we should be negotiating with
the north we want the United States and
we want to talk with the president said
don't do it he imposed those sanctions
etc Daponte now here comes president
moon he says oh you know what Jesse
you're just you're here is just divine
just know you look marvelous but he
distracts Jesse my friend Jesse from the
fact that is suddenly the Alliance which
was the u.s. and South Korea against
North Korea is been speaking since 2015
Korea because of the fiery rhetoric and
because of those tough sanctions the
North now came to the table that's a
good thing you know what's interesting
here is that Gregg would suddenly be
looking at that I don't want to insult
the guy but what did trunk on the little
nut or something Rocketman suddenly the
little rocket man is the one who's gonna
determine whether or not Trump is a good
negotiator come on guys give me a break
beat on it so there's been no sanctions
no one had China has not taken if none
of this stuff happened there did China
come along is China really pushed from
China it's a 30% yeah but remember when
the chocolate cake was on the breakfast
table and so yeah we've got it now China
is going to really hit him hard now he
says China hasn't done enough that's
what the president says that's good oh
you shouldn't say what the president our
China to do more